all right I guess that just goes to show
that you can lead a horse to water but
you can't make him but chug we'll see
you next time on every damn day okay
that's a cut guys amazing everybody gets
an Emmy all right those scripts are due
by the end of the day so let's take a
quick lunch walk through it
cool thank you hmm me so hungee
how many like for lunches after this
[Music]
Jordans chewing is tracking anyone yes
yes maybe he's not chewing
maybe he's teething Baba you chew like a
vulture I'm just eating my lunch you
doing a lot more of it I am going to
punch you in the throat fine I guess
I'll just eat this soup I got and said
cool are you chewing on soup if teeth
are the problem I can take them of your
hand
wow I guess soup is bad to just open the
bad girls shove it down the hole punch
in your throat you know what I was
trying to open the bag slowly out of
respect for you guys but I guess lunch
is illegal now you want to suck on a
benign excuse me
oh wow - so I eat with no one's around
and I suck on a peanut to curb lip
between town oh okay yeah sure thanks
sorry my ringtones allowed chewing
sounds thought to be funny but it's not
funny right now Jordan Jordan is just
eating Jordan he's dead what Jordan is
dead and Nate will not be happy about
this
watch out watch out everybody watch out
[Music]
who knows our planet again so
well I'm sorry it's okay I think we all
deserve to chew loudly today
[Music]
you